tous les jours de beau temps les mordus
de tennis se donnent rendez vous sur le
terrain
happy tech on pourrait dire que l'école
de gabriel stacké est un laboratoire
pour les jeunes talents roumain il a
entraîné plusieurs championnes
nationales fonds propres fils radu est
un athlète décoré il avait 7 ans quand
il a commencé à jouer avec une petite
fille du même âge qui venait tout juste
d'arriver du canada dire que bien cadrer
ce coup n'avait jamais frappé une seule
base de la moto au feeling
extraordinaire entraîneur j'ai tout de
suite eu un sentiment extraordinaire
avec elle se rappelle gabriel chez lui
donc avec des qualités rares histoires
d'enfants ambitieux foire sérieuses
menaces brisé en trois ans gabriel denys
la base le reste appartient à l'athlète
phénoménal il est partout elle triomphe
lien cadre les secours ne rate jamais
l'occasion de saluer son héritage sim
toi tu oublieras dîner chez des femmes
il ya machitos peter
bien que né au canada a vécu une partie
de son enfance ici revient chaque année
pour les vacances et le débat fait rage
à savoir si elle est à nous ou si les
canadiens raconte gabriel en riant dans
mon cas mais difficile de trouver un
fan-club plus enthousiastes que celui de
weid est le petit village de ses parents
hier j'ai dominé elle est devenue un
phénomène mondial et pour moi elle est
une merveille de sa grande-tante
elisabetta son mari raconte même qui a
dû fermer la télévision pendant la
finale du us open parce qu'ils avaient
des palpitations à voter pour son mari
mais quand il l'a rouvert pour voir bien
qu'à monter dans les estrades embrasser
ses parents la pression je suis petit
brusquement dit il quelle fierté de
l'avoir gagné un si jeune âge car la
seule autre roumaine qui aura atteint ce
niveau dit il et simona les met son
ascension n'a rien à voir avec celle de
biens cacao explosive dont notre billet
en cas une véritable explosion
c'est important et c'est même précieux
pour la roumanie dit hey hey hey dj le
no sukkiri romy appel transmis après
tout c'est notre sang jamie les gènes de
valdaï plaisante la famille
une région reconnue pour sa longue
lignée de bergers et bergères tonna ce
fut même une époque où sa grand mère
maternelle en est est elle nous a reçus
avec photos et reliques de sa petite
prodige canado roumaine dont elle admire
l'ambition et le courage et l explique
comment son coeur déborde de joie de la
voix ganic wiimote et j'en pleure et
janry chaque fois de sa grand mère qui
ne compte plus les voyages qu'elle a
faits au canada pour aider sa fille
maria et nutella décision de ses parents
de s'installer là bas quand bien qu
avait dix ans elle n'aurait pu exploiter
son talent dira d'où son premier
partenaire de jeu des causes l'état
roumain estime ne finance pas les jeunes
espoirs points au dessus ça n'existe pas
aujourd'hui bien cadré secours s'inscrit
dans cette nouvelle génération de
joueurs en or dans lesquels tennis
canada investit au fil des ans
[Applaudissements]
pis tech au plus grand tournoi du monde
gabriel prédit que bien qu andré straus
un jour numéro à chopard est toujours
près de la famille et admet qu'une
petite partie lui était avec elle sur le
terrain quand elle a battu serena
williams elle est un modèle pour ses
élèves c'est une source d'inspiration
sans beau site à marc altérer ce coup
radio-canada api tech en roumanie